and then i just became mandem i just
became one of the boys and you see that
key of navigating around the boys it is
so i think it's very true
why do you think it's okay in society
for
us to say men are trash but it's not
okay for men to say women are horrors
even though it's more true i think they
can
okay oh wait women do you think do you
think on a public platform if yeah you
have a podcast if you went on your
podcast and just said modern women are
horses
wait but is that a generalization right
but but women but women generalize all
the time they say they're afraid to walk
alone at night
i think
i think women call themselves [ __ ] in
different ways so they call themselves
sugar babies they call himself
but we're not talking about the women
i'm saying like why is that okay in
society
because it means that you have to accept
that the opposite sex and acknowledges
your flaw and they acknowledge that you
are a [ __ ] that's what it is
no women are sensitive
i think you know when another woman you
know as a joke say oh you're a bee or
you know you're a [ __ ] yeah they say
like oh it's candy it's cute and candied
but when a man says it's you you know
like when a guy says to you you don't
look good in those clothes you know he
means that he's not going to say he's
not going to say like just to be
horrible if he's telling you oh darling
you're a [ __ ] he means who means you
know what it is you've kind of been
caught because sometimes i feel like
girls will be like
i've done the same friendship group it
means you're when a man has to open his
mouth and say honestly yeah for him
because you know men don't care about
stuff men those men only talk when they
need to you're [ __ ] babes i think a
woman a woman's got to maintain a social
capital
so a man being able to call her a [ __ ]
just diminishes her social capital
because
that's that's who you your of value too
you're not of value to other girls
you're value to men so especially if the
guy is the guy that you like if you see
an attractive guy call you a horse game
it's game over
what do you think
no i agree honestly because if a guy
came up to me and said i'm a [ __ ] i
would just
i'd just think my life would say well
i'll never get my reads have you seen
men mental trash before
100 i've said it before i have said it
before yeah did you mean it no
i don't think all men are trash
that's a lie yes i do
majority
i think when you're young like it's easy
to be like this and that you know when
you grow up and there's life experiences
life humbles you exactly and i think you
realize everyone's got a bit of mental
health everyone's traumatic no
people need therapy
girls are [ __ ] the same guys and then
they're calling those guys and most men
don't have sex
so then you do you go for a certain type
of woman because you've sat here and
said mostly i'm an international citizen
but then you said most women are crazy
so you go for crazy women no i i i know
women who are crazy kind of experienced
crazy women i remember like i said i do
this i talk to women on a regular basis
so i get stories from women who i don't
need to interact on a normal basis and
they will tell me certain things like i
know girls who have stopped their
boyfriend from getting their dream job
because he was going to break up with
her
yeah
spiteful is that like crazy crazy stuff
don't you think that my job like i think
everybody needs therapy
yeah
i do advocate for very people i'm saying
that
the type of man that you deem attractive
is very very small represents a small uh
minority of men which means that he has
all the options which also means that
the guys you're calling trash
are only trash cause you're all sleeping
with the same men then you want to go
around and say oh men are this i mean
that there's a whole breath of men out
there he will treat you well but you
ignore those ones to sleep with the ones
that your friends stand with your
cousin's gonna sleep with your best
friend's gonna sleep with and the men
are trash when really it's the guys
you're letting inside so what so why why
do you think it's okay to say that to
say what like men are trash you just
said you do think that why do you think
they're trying to feel good say the
women's side honestly yeah i feel like
my recent experiences have really opened
my eyes okay men of um from all
different walks of life not that i have
slept with them for somebody else's that
that i've experienced i've seen married
women married men come to talk to me
that seemed that they're in happy
relationships i'm like wow so even the
married ones cheat i've seen people that
are my age
um at trash i've seen people that are
traumatized at us people who've been
through therapy at trash i feel like
i've just seen
all men act trash so that's why i say
that who cheats more men are women women
don't get caught i feel like men men
cheat more honestly i feel like
mentioning
the rates are similar
yeah
yeah and i and i think women lie more
who lies more men are women women women
so by that logic wouldn't you say that
women get away with cheating more yeah
no but i feel like for women is wow so
so would you say that women are equally
trash
no because i feel like women cheat when
there's a reason men cheat because as
you guys said that their hormones make
them cheap so so 20 of men are in
sexless marriages would you say that's a
good reason that if you're not having
sex with your husband that he should
cheat
yeah yeah okay so would you say and the
cheating status about twenty-five
percent of men would you say that's a
good reason
yeah
yeah i mean you're young right but i'm
saying like life is going to show you
like life will humble you
and like life at some point you have to
take accountability for the men you date
okay and like every situation you're in
is your own fault like just
like everything again if you're the
common denominator with all these trash
men why are they interacting with you
and also can i can i just add majority
of the people that say men are trash one
they've never been raised maybe by their
father i've had no interaction outside
of sexual so their idea of men is just
what
what can that man do for me uh in a
sexual way and in a financial way so
they will say men are trash when they
don't get sex they don't get financial
gain the the ga the man resists her her
drive for him to do what she wants so we
have to look at these factors i'm me
personally i've never said men are trash
because i see the benefits that they
bring to my life
family wise friend no honestly i have i
have had no reason to say
men are trash
it's a blanket statement when you
appreciate the benefits that men bring
into the arena you actually realize we
need them and they need us isn't it and
i think there's a lot of buzzwords that
just come from tiktok yeah
no actually actually
um
men
don't need women women need men
men could survive without women if all
the women disappeared tomorrow men would
be fine outside of reproduction
women women need men so they need us for
reproduction yeah so that's a poor form
yeah if if tomorrow they made artificial
wombs what would they need a woman for
well
they need eggs
okay who's a better who's a better
companion men are women man
yeah but what's the capacity but what's
the capacity for that companionship you
know
outside of children and if you if you
could get a hooker
model
so men built the world
every like all the hard jobs are done by
men if we if men disappeared tomorrow
they would society would collapse ben
built the world that we complain about
yeah but without women they can't be men
they literally can't generate outside
outs no outside i'm saying but outside
of that what what do they need women for
i would say arguably one of the driving
forces for
men doing what they do is women it's
women i'd say i was going to ask him
he's married like because i feel like
comparing this world for women but then
do you think outside of what i'm saying
what i'm saying is men could survive
without women
because men can be alone women can't
women are social beings
we thrive we need attention
yeah and men men don't so a man can like
live by himself in like you don't see
women going out to the woods and just
roughing it that's a man thing
you know
who's camping and fishing it's not us
that's true like all the hard jobs are
done by men and and so
even so like you still say things like
men are trash and it's no hate like
you're 21 so i'm not like most girls do
at that age it's not i feel like when
they say it correct me from wrong i feel
like when they say it's in the context
of like relationships that's what she
was saying like outside of relationships
when you've got other males around you
whether it's a brother father or
whatever you appreciate men anyway just
for the other things yeah
yeah but then they'll go and say men are
trash anyway which is a very broad
statement and that's what i'm saying
it's a buzzword they don't mean it
because in their lives they want the men
that they have no no i genuinely think
i'm not saying every girl means it but
like society hates that even even look
at look at everything on tv it's always
the the dumb dad what's on the simpsons
it's everything everything watch
commercials it's always like the guy
doing something stupid the woman coming
to the rescue women are queens women
empowerment women women women there's no
men's empowerment people would laugh
yeah but that's so it disenfranchises
men men are more likely to take risks
than women men put themselves on the
line in more scenarios than women men
put themselves forward physically
in the place of a family it's only
because of this society that we're
currently in where they give it with
this full sense of you can be at the
front of the line you can do this like
if there was a scenario where there was
actually danger right now you know every
moment
every man in this room where you
naturally
make sure that every woman in this room
is absolutely and they accept that
but then when it comes to the financial
um the household the work now it's all
about where equals women empowerment we
can do it by ourselves but really we
need each other and that's how it's it's
by design what i'm saying biologically
yeah i'm saying women
men don't need women outside of
reproduction
[Music]
it's true society has just made those
it's true
this is a humbling like stat that's why
people don't like this is a humbling
fact of life and that's why women don't
like to hear it
well i can't because it means we're not
as important as we think we are well i
think that
for me
i know i can see the benefits of having
men around as a woman
i aim to be a benefit to the men in my
life
and if i if i'm not okay i step to the
side and let other people step into that
role i'm not a person that will be
overly both like bolstered up and say i
am this and i'm that but i think in the
way of the world outside of this
societal um
western mentality
we sit together and we we both add value
we could say oh men could survive on
their own but realistically who wants to
have